[Musica]
confesso che quando ho saputo il titolo
di questo incontro non mi è venuto un
colpo perché è dalla notte dei tempi che
le menti più illuminate cercano di dare
una risposta a questa domanda e quindi
io che non sono
non so niente di filosofia non conosco
il punto di vista delle neuroscienze
non sono un artista non sono una
creativa ero così non sapevo che cosa
che cosa avrei potuto raccontarvi poi mi
sono resa conto che l'unica soluzione
che avevo era quella di raccontare la
mia esperienza di parlare della mia
esperienza quindi di quello che credo
dentro di me abbia mosso
la bellezza è così vi parlerò della mia
interpretazione che è un'interpretazione
fatta con i piedi è nata grazie a quello
che ho raccolto dalla terra camminandoci
dentro in un passo dopo l'altro in
decenni di vita passati a scalare le
montagne in giro per il mondo
vorrei cominciare con una storia che si
svolge nello sinkiang l'antico turkestan
orientale è una regione immensa della
cina che è abitata da un minestrone di
etnia uiguri tagiki kirghisi e anche
cinesi e il mese di giugno del 1994 e da
giorni
stiamo camminando dentro un isola di
vuoto che si allunga a fianco del
taklamakan il deserto e il famoso
deserto da cui non si torna indietro
ci stiamo muovendo come un'antica caro
maniera perché stiamo seguendo il passo
dei cammelli che le navi del deserto i
nostri animali sono divisi in gruppi di
4 5 legati sono legati uno all'altro da
un anello al naso e sulla schiena
trasporto nei bidoni con il nostro
materiale a condurli ci sono una decina
di cammellieri sono i guri tagiki e
kirghisi sono lingue etnie diverse e
quello che li accomuna è la terra è
quella terra primordiale
noi siamo in 14 e quello che ci lega è
l'oggetto del nostro desiderio il k2 che
vogliamo conoscere non dalla sua faccia
famosa quella della conquista italiana
del 54
ma dal suo lato nascosto e poco
conosciuto che è il versante nord e da
qualche parte avevamo visto una
fotografia è quello che ci aveva
lasciati senza fiato era la bellezza
della sua forma da quel versante che è
un triangolo perfetto e ancora di più ci
aveva colpiti la linea perfetta dello
spigolo che da quel dalla base lo risale
ininterrotto fino alla cima 8.611 metri
e così eravamo lì che un passo dopo
l'altro ci stavamo addentrando dentro
questo mondo sconosciuto con il
desiderio di andare a toccare a sfiorare
la bellezza di quella linea perfetta che
nessuno aveva mai salito eravamo lì
siamo arrivati a fine giugno al al
fronte del ghiacciaio
mancano ancora 25 chilometri per
arrivare ai piedi della montagna
però i cammelli devono fermarsi lì
quindi scaricano il materiale e se ne
torna nei villaggi verranno a
riprenderci fra 50 giorni e fino a quel
momento noi saremo completamente soli
senza telefono senza collegamenti e
senza sapere se il mondo fuori esiste
ancora e siamo lì per terra ci sono le
impronte dei cammelli davanti abbiamo la
forma perfetta del k2 e tutt'intorno
nient'altro che il silenzio
in altre parole siamo in mezzo al mondo
come era prima e come sarà dopo di noi
dopo l'uomo sono insieme a romano
a differenza sua che era già stato lì
tre anni prima
per me è la prima esperienza su sun
8.000 o un bagaglio di esperienza
maturato in tanti anni di scalate sulle
alpi però questa sarà un'esperienza
completamente nuova e cercherò di
affrontarlo un passo per volta fin dove
fin dove ci riuscirò quindi tornando lì
siamo completamente soli siamo soli allo
sbaraglio in una libertà che è senza
senza confini e soli e responsabili di
vivere
adesso ci aspetteranno tutti i 25 km
dovremo trasportare tutto il materiale
fino ai piedi della montagna e da lì
iniziare la salita e sarà un viaggio
nuovo perché la strada ce la dovremo ce
la dovremo inventare noi ce la dovremo
inventare da soli
è un viaggio che ti inghiotte è un
viaggio che ti inghiotte ti mette in
disordine la vita perché lì le certezze
i riferimenti che abbiamo a casa non
valgono niente anzi ti ti illudono
pericolosamente di poter controllare la
situazione ma in realtà li e la natura
che decide e quindi adesso non solo
dovremo affrontare il pericolo oggettivo
della salita ma dovremo affrontare anche
il rischio di sentirsi persi
e allora per non affogare nell'angoscia
l'unica soluzione è quella di cambiare i
passi della danza
e allora per prima cosa bisogna avere
delle poche regole condivise e quindi
autosufficienza fisica e psicologica
pazienza umiltà approccio consapevole al
pericolo è prima di tutto la certezza
che li o si perde o si vince tutti
insieme poi in secondo luogo bisogna
accettare di vivere
l'ignoto
l'ignoto sia fuori ma anche dentro di
noi e per quanto possa sembrare assurdo
bisogna cercare di affidarsi alla
montagna il 31 luglio siamo pronti per
tentare la cima come cordata dava
scoperta siamo in tre romano filippo e
io e quelli che stiamo facendo sono i
primi passi umani che tracciano quella
linea che che è intatta da sempre
facciamo un ultimo bivacco a 7.800 metri
partiamo in un'alba freddissima alle 14
oltrepassiamo gli 8.400 metri ancora
convinti che ci fosse il collegamento
fra lo spigolo e la cima a 8400 50
scopriamo che il passaggio non c'è e che
la nostra via dalla bellezza pura
finisce lì su una torre che è
completamente staccata dalla parete
la mia reazione a differenza dei miei
due compagni non è stata molto signorile
e ricordo che mentre scendevamo verso il
campo base filippo mi ripeteva una frase
una frase di oscar wilde
quando gli dèi ci vogliono punire
ascoltano le nostre preghiere
ci è voluto
mi ci è voluto parecchio tempo per
mandare giù il rospo perché non capivo
perché
la nostra via fosse finita lì perché
mancavano solo 150 metri alla cima
stavamo bene eravamo presto le
condizioni del tempo e della parete
erano buone
quindi non capivo perché e poi pian
piano l'ho capito ho capito perché gli
dei non avevano ascoltato le mie
preghiere perché avevano voluto che
imparassi da subito ad accettare il
fallimento senza scoraggiarmi e difatti
e da quella cima mancata che è
cominciato il cammino che ha portato me
romano a salire in cima a tutti i 14
ottomila
ma non è stato per un desiderio di
rivalsa ma piuttosto per una voglia di
continuare a metterci in gioco a
esplorare sempre con il desio di
desiderio di andare di cercare di
toccare quella quella bellezza perché la
bellezza non smette mai di chiamarci e
quando ne siamo colpiti
non abbiamo paura a voltare le spalle
alle sicurezze per cercare di
raggiungerla magari anche a fatica un
passo per volta
anzi è meglio la paura c'è la paura di
affrontare l'ignoto la paura di perderci
ma la accettiamo come una compagna di
viaggio e anzi a dire il vero è anche
utile perché lei che ci fa mantenere
desta l'attenzione che ci permette anche
di trovare le soluzioni più economiche
ai problemi che ci si presentano lungo
il percorso
a una condizione però che quando saremo
lontani dalle sicurezze dovremmo
imparare a sospendere i giudizi e
accettare di vivere un futuro incerto
sconosciuto perché solo in questa
maniera riusciremo ad
dirci all'ascolto in questa maniera a
trovare nuovi equilibri non solo fuori
ma anche dentro di noi e c'è anche la
possibilità degli yacht dell'insuccesso
del fallimento certo ma a quel punto
torneremo indietro con uno sguardo
diverso perché avremo intravisto la
possibilità di nuovi percorsi e
soprattutto torneremo indietro
consapevoli che l'imprevedibile esiste e
che la vita è la realtà non è fatta di
opposti perché così come c'è il giorno
la notte il sole la pioggia i successi
fallimenti e allo stesso modo c'è il
coraggio e la paura la forza e la
fragilità ma gli opposti sono come le
due facce di una medaglia che solo
quando le mette insieme la compongono e
ti restituiscono la bellezza della
medaglia e allo stesso modo anche noi
siamo la sintesi di tutti i nostri
dritti ai nostri rovesci
e a quel punto il fallimento ti apparirà
semplicemente per quello che è ossia una
tappa del nostro percorso ostia la cima
la cima del k2 poi è arrivata è arrivata
a dodici anni dopo al terzo tentativo
k2 salito è disceso da me romano in
completa solitudine in cinque giorni
e perché l'altra spedizioni pensavano
che non ci fossero le condizioni
eccetera eccetera
siamo arrivati sul 26 luglio del 2006
eravamo i romano soli su tutta la
montagna e l'abbiamo chiamato il nostro
k in due ed eravamo lì non abbiamo
sventolato bandierine non abbiamo alzato
le braccia in segno di trionfo
semplicemente ce ne stiamo stati lì
accovacciati a terra a guardarci intorno
e con lo sguardo potevamo abbracciare
l'orizzonte e soprattutto è stato un
momento una sensate un attimo di grande
chiarezza e una sensazione pacificante
perché eravamo immersi
nella consolante vastità dell'universo e
non la guardava mon eravamo parte ea
quel punto l'unica cosa che ci è venuta
spontanea è stato semplicemente un
grazie e spero di riuscire a leggervi
due righe 2 che ho scritto in una sera
in un campo base
adesso è sera e credo di non avere mai
visto una notte così piena di stelle dal
nero profondo un crepitio di luci ci sta
piovendo addosso grandi piccole
brillanti tenui alcune lanciano lame di
luce e altre pulsano pacate e sullo
sfondo un tappeto il fitto di puntini
luccicanti come se una mano gigantesca
li avesse seminati a manciate e noi due
qua sotto
immersi nella grazia di questa notte
dove insieme danzano terra luna sole e
stelle che bello sarebbe se la bellezza
fosse contagiosa
grazie
[Applauso]